[Music]
on the dish this morning Justin coochie
raised in a legendary New York
restaurant from childhood coochie spent
time overseas then down south before
settling in Denver where his food and
restaurant locations have brought him
plenty of attention one of his
restaurants is a former Mortuary we sat
down with coochie inside a building that
used to house 45
000 Corpses
you learn to walk in a dining room yeah
uh as soon as I was old enough to be
dragged to the restaurant it was my
daycare so basically learning to walk
talk flirt anything I could as a young
child started in the Waverly Inn flirt
it took a little while to get to that
point but I got a lot of attention from
early on sometimes Justin coochie
attracted too much attention
after getting kicked out of boarding
school for smoking and drinking coochie
finished his education in Jerusalem Upon
returning he yearned to buy the Waverly
Inn the fame New York City restaurant
his grandparents owned and ran when that
didn't happen kuchi moved to Florida for
a decade
then turned his wandering eyes West you
said you didn't think there was anything
in between the coasts correct except
corn right and mediocrity I
unfortunately said that yes what made
you change your mind
um I got older I got more mature I got
an open mind and I got to you know I got
sick of the East Coast what are we
making over here so Chef is working on
some paella working on just that
beautiful process of toasting the rice
today coochie has opened and overseas
six restaurants in Denver shishito
peppers on top salsa verde garlic
including linger what are you trying to
do with the roof deck here you know the
roof deck was just about the city and
the open air Denver has more sunny days
in Florida where he hauled a
recreational vehicle Up on the Roof a
bar v a bar V so it's an RV that's a bar
exactly
it's in 1975 Old School GMC I think it
was in the movie Stripes gentlemen this
is the em50 urban assault vehicle it is
not the actual urban assault vehicle
from Stripes it's Czechoslovakia it's
like going into Wisconsin but it is same
model same year and so now it's just a
full-on bar it is also not the most
interesting thing about this place
the name linger has been shortened from
Olinger formerly the largest Mortuary in
Denver they didn't leave anything behind
they did a good job cleaning up
advertised with a giant neon sign not
everyone is thrilled when they find out
that 45 000 corpses
used to occupy yes this space totally
what do they say you know we try not to
make that a talking point but it is a
talking point there's been many people
early on who when they found out
sometimes in the middle of the meal that
this was a mortuary they asked for their
check if the ex-mortuary isn't enough
coochie also has Ophelia's a former
brothel as well as vital Roots L5 and
Root Down
when combined they show off an Eclectic
collection of bites pulled from every
part of coochies feacened mind this is
Farm to Table with a global approach I
like that we started with lingers bow
buns duck pork belly and Korean Fried
Chicken
Ophelia's spring Cheese Incident from L5
Egyptian eggplant fries and matzo ball
soup dumplings so much of this is about
a little flavor color in this yeah
flavor bomb flavor bomb yeah and it's
just trying we're always trying to make
food really craveable celebrating the
ingredients and then the flavors that go
on it we moved on to root Downs Devils
on Horseback peppadew Peppers wrapped in
tender belly bacon and they're veggie
sliders with sweet potato fries
a sunflower seed risotto from vital
roots and a linger signature Dosa a
fermented lentil and rice crepe with two
kinds of Chutney and Masala potatoes how
do I eat this you know my tear a piece
off it's like a hat
they're always really big they're
they're supposed to be larger than the
plate um and do I get the action inside
I would get the action inside I'll just
crack this open this is like cutting
that Lobster open for desserts Moshi
cornbread with smoked green tea angles
and blackberry mousse
feluda panna cotta and zeppoli Italian
style Donuts
all this food is now served in kuchi's
restaurants by the owner
that is no longer coochie
he sold the company back to his workers
we're actually now it's a hundred
percent play-owned I think the simplest
way to say it is it felt like the right
thing to do it just felt like this
industry really
um I don't want to say uses people but
it can definitely wear on people it can
definitely grind on people especially
the invisible people right the people
who maybe don't make this their career
and just come for a pit stop along the
way
one of the sections in his cookbook
edible Beach is devoted to coochie's
dishwashers I guess maybe being a little
bratty kid in New York
um I got to spend time with the
dishwashers because everybody wanted me
out of their way chefs would not allow
me in the kitchen I was definitely like
you know Annoying the service at some
point but the dishwasher you know that
we had specifically I can remember just
was always so incredibly
um you know protective and inviting and
I just know you know feel choked up
talking about but I know how hard he
worked and how much he put into that
restaurant The Clement
by that time coochie's emotions hadn't
even been infused by drink
which of course he served this is our
zombie uh lime juice passion fruit juice
grapefruit juice three kinds of rum some
smoked cinnamon uh and this is a plan of
French uh 75 it's called the French Kiss
so this is a zombie this is the French
Kiss are we doing a zombie or a
friendship we're gonna do the zombie
because these we only allow people to
order I think it's one per person
because they're really strong wow
they're really amazing and so these are
just like you want to top off the night
this is the way to do it cheers cheers
thanks for hosting us yeah thank you
yeah one per person
you were quiet there was some debate
about whether it's one per person or two
but either way there's like three kinds
of rum in here so this is designed one
sip per person at this table Yeah but
it's refreshing you know what really got
to me
um what he said about the dishwashers
but I sense from a lot of chefs that the
pandemic really gave them a level of
appreciation of people that are often
unseen and it's it's one of the chefs I
dealt with the one in Portugal had
dedicated a whole his website to to his
cleaning there's a section devoted to
dishwashers as another section devoted
to dogs his current dogs and former dogs
yeah um so it's really the the book
edible beat is really very interesting
but he's just I mean he's so creative
well in his appreciation obviously that
was stems from job it's awesome yeah
great great job